teuf et je pas là seulement pour faire
votre promo ah bon ben non vous êtes là
aussi pour tester les nouvelles
interviews que je vais faire après des
vraies stars ya pas de problème y'a pas
de problème vous est pris on va faire
l'interview sigla on ne bouge pas
pendant le jingle
[Musique]
m
pour vous le progrès ces tgv ou ivg
et toi tu vas le faire des vraies stars
ouais
je vais cependant je prends mon premier
joker jean-pierre ouais je vais donner
l'avis du public ouais est ce que la
démocratie a plus à craindre de letea ou
de l'ena
le nom lainages et une fois j'ai joué
j'ai joué dans une école pour une école
c'est le polytechnique c'est incroyable
ce speed un truc de fou quand j'avais
pas fini les phrases ils rigolaient déjà
il avait déjà compris la gran ils sont
impressionnants ils font peur
notre vie sexuelle
votre vie sexuelle c'est plutôt sas
ras ou sos c'est plutôt s
sas ouais bah ouais tant qu'à faire
maintenant que j'y suis puisque chaque
fois je dis je passe pour un obsédé
votre vision de la vie conjugale c'est
plutôt cdd cdi ou sdf
en ce moment c'est ce qui m'inquiète
c'est plutôt cdi mais souvent elles
s'engagent et puis après on se fait
battre à la porte on se retrouve sdf
donc j'attends un bon moment c'est
plutôt sur la longue durée c'est plutôt
ça ouais là c'est vraiment l'amour
nov la soirée à laquelle vous êtes prêts
à tout faire pour pas y aller ah c'est
bhl et la nrf
pdg et hec ou om et psg
c'est sûrement pas la troisième là ça
c'est sûr non par contre maintenant ça
serait justement de regarder un match om
psg chez bhl avec des pdg
titeuf ce que vous regardez en premier
chez une fille son cv son rib ou son qi
sokü
les trois lettres qui vous font fuir
devant une fille ces mst ou mlf
même et c'est vrai que l'efs nom
isabelle alonso ces coquines d'abord
contrairement à l'image que tu as touché
pas l'image qu'elle veut se donner donc
la valeur sauf pour les plus tôt mlf oui
oui je suis pour je dois regarder une
caméra oui il faut dire elle isabelle si
un jour on se rencontre
en discutera
je ferai pas le match y
être pas tout de suite mais après
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le il
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu